Oh make myself at home hang out right
here like a vertical bed hi I'm Kristin
and I'm here with realtor.com and we're
gonna go help Hanna find a new house my
dad's in town and we're going to look
for a new home for me I'm here to help
her avoid the pitfalls of all first-time
homebuyers
we're gonna go house shopping super
exciting get some inspiration for when I
finally create my own awesome amazing
place it's super fun to like kind of
play house with someone you've been
saving up a lot in the same way yeah
over the last like a year and a half
I've really sort of take into account
that I'm an adult it's horrible horrible
feeling first things first what is your
budget
I would like to figure that out it's
really fun looking for a house you
finally get to think about all the
things you actually want and not just
the things you're gonna settle for I
don't know what this side of my dresser
looks like a little too nervous to open
it for fear of hitting my head again the
most important thing is location who
give you time to work 38 minutes that's
not bad that's like one podcast she's
transitioning from adulthood to mega
adulthood I entertain a lot my little
two-bedroom is starting to get a little
cramped so we can't cut the friend
budget no I'm also like a dishwasher
review awesome I was like oh there's
nothing oh wow so you can pre scout your
neighborhood yeah oh my god restaurants
is it a safe area though that's very
important yes I'm it's really good
I would like Hanna to not have a
fixer-upper if you're gonna buy a house
you want to be able to enjoy that house
right away yeah I feel like it's
something that a lot of people in their
20s are like well just take what I got
and I guess I'll just live here not for
Hannah Hannah's gonna have what she
wants
you're mine good morning are you ready
to go inside take a look I had enough
coffee so we're good okay that's better
than the one you've got it's better than
the one I love it because it's working
yes look at this island I love this so
much
oh so this is like an office space you
imagine having like my desk right here
and look even with slanted I can still
pick it is a not full of stuff I figured
like you know like a nice little like
table grill maybe some bocce ball well
that might be more for you but yes I'm
guessing this is the master bedroom
because of this ridiculous walk-in
closet definitely what is this if you
guys just want to go out look I'll be
here for a while okay there's enough
room for everyone to come into the tub
wait wait wait
oh my god this looks perfect
can we go see it yeah hey how's it going
oh my god take a look yes spice let's go
high ceilings so beautiful this little
seating area flam this is like a great
we have like a little conversation
look at this daybed this is her reading
nook this field okay here's the bathroom
oh all right okay so it's not like the
last one no but I you know what I feel
like this is such a great home and I
love it too much already I feel like
this would be a very easy upgrade hey
guys check out the barn door this is
what I would do every single day it's
just this oh wow yeah this is so
beautiful
what's it here what are these catacombs
you need to explore this is their
treasure oh my god do you need some
breadcrumbs to get out this window or
shows what's up good looking and that's
for the puppy hey Madison there and how
much that puppy in the window oh we're
here with the dead jokes this is
so stunning I can do all my baking right
here and build a cake this high oh he's
gonna love it
oh wow what a massive backyard I have
always wanted an ivy-covered wall this
is like dream secured all right now that
we've seen both houses tell us about
what you thought about the first house
well I loved how modern it looked on the
island for the kitchen was unbelievable
I didn't love the location I thought it
was a little far out of the way the
price is better though and it is newer
which makes maintenance a whole lot
better for you so what about this place
that well my absolute favorite thing
about this house is a sec you walk in
you really feel like you're home that's
true because I did to the natural
lighting was perfect the one thing I'm
worried about is it's quite a bit of an
older home and they're things like you
know that guest bathroom I feel like it
would need an upgrade of some sort so
well if I had to pick one I have to say
I think it would be this house
well all I gotta do is get a realtor and
get the ball rolling this is where it
all begins so let's talk about our dog
okay what's this name do I have to share
[Music]